In the Pacific Ocean between Australia and New Zealand
is a barren sea spire that is home to the worlds rarest insect
and what an insect it is!
This is Ball’s Pyramid
It is 1843 feet tall, it's 50% taller than the Empire State Building
and it juts out of the pacific ocean
it looks like a super villains lair
and in a funny way, if you are really afraid of huge insects
it is a super villains lair
Meet Dryococelus Australis, more commonly known as the Lord Howe Stick Insect
but also referred to as the Walking Sausage
and the Tree Lobster.
It used to live on Lord Howe Island which is where it got its name.
It’s a larger island that is about 11 km away from Ball’s Pyramid.
So in 1918 a ship the SS Makambo ran aground on Lord Howe Island
Black Rats escaped from the ship and found waiting for them
a delightful treat, in the form of the Lord Howe Stick Insect
they’re pretty slow, they’re really big, and they probably taste delicious
If you’re a rat
it only took them two years to drive the stick insect to extinction
by 1920 there was not another report of a living Lord Howe Island Stick Insect.
So it wasn’t until 2001 that a couple of entomologists finally made it out to Ball’s Pyramid
to basically prove that the stick insect was extinct
and they got there and they started looking around
they came across a single bush
they discovered living, after 80 years
of being thought extinct
the last 24 Lord Howe Island Stick Insects in the world
the Lord Howe Stick Insect was back from the dead
and they all live under one tiny bush
on the side of Ball’s Pyramid in the middle of the Pacific Ocean
once they discovered these insects
they wanted to start a breeding program
they took four of these stick insects, two of them died in the first week
that left only two, one male and one female
which they of course named Adam and Eve
and after some coaxing and near death experiences of Eve
they were actually able to begin their captive breeding program
they have bred well over a thousand adults
and twenty thousand eggs at this point
they are on their way to quite a healthy population of Walking Sausages
which led some people to say
It’s a real walking sausage party in here
so after surviving for 80 years in isolation on Ball’s Pyramid
the stick insect is finally going to be reintroduced to it’s island home
whether the locals of the island will be pleased to replace their rats
with equally large nocturnal stick insects  remains to be seen
there is something to be said about being proud of your local species
however terrifying they may be
click here to subscribe or click here to watch our other videos
unusually for insects they form bonded mating pairs, one male and one female
and when they sleep the male cuddles the female big spoon style
it’s really nice
I want to hear what other nicknames you think this wonderful creature should have
I think Tree Lobster and Walking Sausage are pretty good
so let me know in the comments
what you think we should calling the Lord Howe Stick Insect